tous les jours pour moi tous les matins
et me préparer c'est vraiment un
exercice qui est quand même long il y
deux ans et demi je suis tombé lors de
l'acrobatie en danse swing et puis je me
suis d'enfants casser le cou puis je
suis devenu sur le sol et h un jeu
devenu tétraplégique bons sentiments mon
comportement d'achat beaucoup changé
depuis mon extrait mon maximum je peux
je n'achète plus spontanément une part
de vêtements je regardais pour des trucs
qui sont super spécifiques
il faut toujours être conscients pour
moi en tout cas pas moi qui fait que je
suis assis dans ma chaise pour 12 heures
donc assis dans la même position
tout ce qui est sur un pantalon tout ce
qui va être une petite pression donc
maintenant derrière l'église va y avoir
les poches les coutures sur les poches
on fait pour exercer des pressions
j'ai pas de détruire c'est donc pour
étendre mes coups du conte président je
suis pas très forte
si c'est trop rigide pas aussi
extensible j'aurais absolument aucune
force pour monter mon parfum body fois
le beau il veut coopérer dès fois pau
puis le sillage peut les tirer
je suis atteint d'une petite fille
muscle a depuis ma naissance je suis en
fauteuil roulant depuis environ 14 15
ans mais quand ce puis je vais utiliser
le ras bord du lit peau douce et avec
elles le sont pour c'est pas parfait
mais ça fait mon affaire
souvent les adaptations que j'ai fait là
c'est en côtoyant d'autres personnes en
fauteuil roulant j'ai mis à un élastique
pour éviter que j'ai besoin la ceinture
ici puis ça m'évite de mettre le bouton
à toutes les fois en très pratique
c'est aussi facile pour que j'enlève le
djing j'ai également mis un anneau
vraiment sympa un anneau pour les clés
après man la fermeture éclair dont aussi
simple que de tirer comme ça
puis je peux toujours rentrer là nos
alentours du bouton pour pas que les les
épreuves descente ce que je fais dans
mon pantalon pour être capable d'aller à
la toilette tout ça c'est m une
ouverture entre les jambes je vais
pouvoir ouvrir les yeux
je vais être capable de faire mon nid
élimination urinaires de cette façon là
donc on a complètement le l'entrejambe
voir si j'ai fait poser des petits
rubans et puis ce qui se passe dans fond
c'est qu'une fois que les pantalons il
revient à peu près à la hauteur des
hanches
je vais passer mes mains à l'intérieur
puis on voit que je n'ai pas du tout de
résistance au niveau du pouce dont je le
rentre vraiment loin puis une fois qui
ronge un prêt à loos le je vais avoir
assez de force avec mon but c'est pour
montrer mon pantalon plus voir ma taille
moi je suis né avec ma maladie donc j'ai
appris à développer mais adaptation au
fur et à mesure mais pour d'autres
personnes c'est au contraire parce qu'il
a imaginé tes où vous avez un accident
vous tombez en fauteuil du jour au
lendemain qu'est ce qui existe moi je
crois pas qu'une grande marque doit se
rendre au niveau de mon handicap
une adaptation c'est très très personnel
même dans la situation où on a les mêmes
handicaps
on n'aura peut-être pas besoin de la
même adaptation moi j'ai la maison avec
les boutons mon voisin qui est en
fauteuil roulant a pas de difficulté
avec les boutons réduire pas
nécessairement besoin d'adaptation pour
les boutons mais il ya certainement des
trucs qui peuvent être faire à ce moment
qu'ils vont a été
considérée comme une adaptation pour
tous peut avoir des gens avec la paresse
du cérébral qui emploie des gens avec la
dystrophie musculaire qui rappelons-le
puis des peut-être des personnes âgées
aussi où ils vont avoir qui ont eu des
avc qui vont avoir la pince plus faibles
donc la paix je veux dire pouce l'index
à quelque chose qui peut vraiment
conseillé dire un objet si on se dit ok
toutes les fermetures à glissière on
rajoute ce petit branleur savait plus
facile les gens peuvent se dire je veux
tirer là dessus c'est pas quelque chose
qui est leur ton adaptation c'est
quelque chose qui peut être utilisé par
tout le monde même les gens qui ont qui
ont pas d'handicap
mais pour quelqu'un qui est en situation
d'handicap c'est un être vraiment grand
succès en fait impossible de le faire
sans